hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we have a review of
episode 3 of doctor stone weapons of
science and here we are back for another
round of rebuilding civilization and
this week was such an incredibly chilled
episode I felt which is weird especially
considering all the tension that was
generated early on but this is why I
love dr. stone because this series has
such a different focus to a traditional
Shonen and its core it's all about
science and exploration which makes it
real easy to just sit down to and be
swept up in whatever journey or
discovery the characters are working on
for example my favorite part of this
week's episode was probably the whole
section with sanku tied you and you
Zahira we're just traveling and seeing
what they run into like the big buddha
or how they logistically managed past
obstacles but Taichi pulling the rafts
thing and the general day-to-day needs
of simple survival and they also think
that this works a lot better in the
anime than it did in the manga which
don't get me wrong and was still nice
and chill in the manga but sometimes
that can be problematic for me because
reading manga is a bit more of an active
experience your eyes are constantly
moving from panel to panel of various
sizes from text to text which could be
anywhere and your imagination is invoked
for voices sound effects or any
perception of color or anything like
that and it's great fun but for sections
like this it really is nice to just have
the anime take care of everything so
that you can just lie back and enjoy the
journey
and one of the characters on set journey
was our newest addition user hero now we
had already gotten a bit of a sense of
her from the first episode but this week
provided a much better taste of what
she'll have to offer going forward and
I'm pretty satisfied with her I guess
her voice is absolutely lovely and
gellick even but when it comes to use a
hero I have deeper problems with her as
a character and that's because doctors
don't is a series that from time to time
can get the bit ropey with certain
characters and that's very much what
user hero feels like to me I like her
design I now like her voice I just wish
she wasn't such a a classically passive
female presence it's not a huge issue
because this series can get away with
little flaws like that just based on its
actual core focus and what I will say
for user here as a character really is
that she is not in any way annoying
which is often the case for the passive
female presence in anime and manga as we
see in this episode she is quick to get
on board with any sort of shenanigan
area to do with singko and tide you
she's not overly serious and in fact she
for some great comic faces from time to
time I just wish she had a bit more
depth to her and you know going forward
that may become a common criticism I
have for other characters but once again
a series like this can
away with it whereas it would be a
crippling detriment to others so as a
result I'm going to say that the anime
has pulled off user hero more or less as
well as they could have and I am looking
forward to seeing more of her in the
animated medium but a character who
continues to grow on me as a result of
his adaptation is most certainly tied
you in this world of Chill that I claim
to love so much he is a much-needed
burst of energy from time to time that
breaks it all up a bit
I mean think of everyone else we have so
far we've got sanku the called genius
use a hero the softly spoken and Tsukasa
who despite being a vicious murderer is
wildly calm and collected so at the
moment I do feels a very important role
if being a dumb loud idiot and it's
something that I greatly appreciate
being done so well in the adaptation but
there is a lot more to him than that and
we get a taste of his true character
here with his conflict against Tsukasa
and I have to say in the manga tied you
is not a character who really held my
interest at all until this moment but he
declares that he refuses to hit people
and that Tsukasa can beat him up as much
as he wants in exchange for not
destroying the stone folk it's such a
wonderfully endearing idiot sort of
thing to say that I could not help but
love him from that moment on and the
anime has made me revisit this point of
conversion all over again and does per
everything else I've mentioned so far it
was handled really well speaking of that
conflict with Tsukasa though the anime
certainly stepped up this week in terms
of action a major criticism that I had
for last week's episode was that
tsukasa's action sequences felt rather
unfortunately pretty weak due to
animation techniques like throwing a
punch and then immediately cutting to
the results thus lessening the overall
impact however during this episode there
was one fantastically animated moment of
Tsukasa grabbing the shot that Cinco
fired from his crossbow and going on to
strike tied you I loved that I could
really feel tsukasa's momentum from the
shot of his foot pivoting all the way
through the sequence the illusion was
sold pretty damn well not phenomenally
compared to more action-based series but
it certainly got the job done for doctor
stone and it gives me some decent hope
for future events now in terms of action
we had one pretty big goal flag this
week being the creation of firearms and
this also happens to be the primary
difference between the anime and the
manga for this episode specifically when
cenk who chooses to reveal that they're
searching for gunpowder in the manga
cent crew pretty blatantly states that
they need to make gunpowder as soon as
Tsukasa leaves their camp which works
quite well in the context of the chapter
because that's what it ends on and it's
a very exciting note but the decision to
move this revelation in the anime was
certainly the correct course of action
because it gave this episode a similar
effect that the manga originally had and
I don't think you miss a lot from not
knowing that they're adventuring for
gunpowder until much later because you
still have that
motivation to flee because there is that
need to separate themselves from Tsukasa
so it was a nice and probably necessary
change for dramatic purposes something
else I think this episode nailed was the
slew of comic faces that appeared and
this was something and I was a bit
afraid of after watching the first
episode because there were comic faces
in the manga that were removed
specifically of sanku and it had me
worried because I thought they might be
trying to portray him as a much more
serious character than he actually is
this week has put all of that to rest as
the series really is starting to
properly embrace its comic layers also
to do it there's a bad transition but
here we are music once again I'm finding
that the music of this series is superb
and the track that specifically stood
out to me here was the one that played
during the conflict with Tsukasa
it was incredibly effective at building
tension and look I'm pathetic with music
so I'm not sure how to properly put this
into words but it also felt distinctly
tribal it's probably not the right word
at all but it was very effective in
evoking a primitive atmosphere so well
done there sadly in terms of music the
ending theme it still hasn't grown me
whatsoever and they still really hate
the visuals that take place in the real
world with the stupid filter and so I'm
probably going to be skipping it from
here on out the opening however is the
exact opposite I love the energy it
brings and I've been listening to the
full version periodically for a couple
of days now and I am still loving it and
the last thing I'd like to mention is
that this is pretty much the end of
volume 1 which is awesome it took just
three episodes to blast through it had a
very decent pace and vol 2 is where
things really start to kick into gear so
I am very excited for the next few weeks
and I hope that you are as well but that
pretty much does it for episode 3 of dr.
stone if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produce in general
then please do consider donating to the
New World review patreon because the
support of all feel amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps plot this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on the episode this has
been the new old review and I'll see you
next time